everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today going to be
continuing our coverage of the 2015
Surak chess challenge we are in round
two today our competitors White's going
to be played by vishy anand and blacks
going to be played by Levon Aronian so
two of the top players in the world
vision on gets the party started with
pawn to d4 as we see him so often do
Knight to f6 pawn to c4 pawn to g6
Knight c3 and then pawn to d5 so giving
in to the Grunfeld defense from black
vishy anand decides to go ahead and not
for the russian system the night here to
f3 after Bishop to a g7 feet hitting on
the King side we see Queen to be three
putting a lot of pressure on the square
here on d5 pretty much forcing blacks
hand to go ahead and take this pawn here
on c4 White's going to recapture here on
c4 so why it definitely has the
advantage in that showing the board in
this variation Black's looking to
counter later on also he can start to
put a lot of pressure on this Queen
that's a little bit exposed not really
supporting into them any other minor or
other major pieces so not something you
want your queen typically to do but if
you can really hold control the center
of the board with this Queen you can
definitely give you benefits down the
end of the road we see castle on the
Kings side upon up here to e4 continuing
the center control in the night to a six
somewhat of it an interesting move it's
the Prince variation it's a variation
that conspire used to play a lot against
Karpov in the world championships when
he used to play so definitely not the
the most uncommon but you don't see it
all that often it is somewhat awkwardly
placed here on a6 a few moves later
after Bishop here to e2 we see pawn here
to see 5c five is the reason for playing
this a six it supports it later on it
you know ideally you would have this
pawn take here on c5 and then this night
could eventually take you know the
bishop come here to e6 first after we
see take bishop here to e6 kind of
forcing this queen away it cannot open
up the door if the rook wants to come
over here to see eight this is going to
be very good but visi non decides to go
and try something different he plays
pawn here too
five and this could be pretty awkward
for Levon Aronian playing two black
pieces because this pawn here on c5
although it does control the center the
board especially this pawn are the
square here on d4 the nights just
awkwardly placed now I can't go anywhere
productive upon here to see five is kind
of blocking it the outpost here on b4 is
not going to do much because just a
simple pawn here to a3 is going to force
that back so not the greatly placed
piece right here on a 60 blacks
definitely going to be looking to move
this into a better square because you
get if it stays here all game that's
definitely going to be very very bad
vishy anand played a similar type of
game like this against Magnus Carlsen in
game 10 of the 2014 World Chess
Championship you go take a look at that
if you want to there's definitely some
slight variations that we see in this
game but he's going to be looking to
push forward with this pawn here and
then again eventually try to promote
this on this D file or if you know if he
wants to he could maybe push this epon
past and get promoted pawn is there we
now see pawn to e6 trying to break up
the center of the board castle in the
Kings side take here on d5 and then
white recaptures here on d5 vision on
doesn't want to go ahead and take with
this pawn here on e6 because again he's
looking to keep this central square here
and so after the exchange is exactly
once he wants to continue to add
pressure here on this D file now the
rook over here to e8 and then he plays
rook to d1 and this is interesting
because in this exact same setup when he
played against Magnus Carlsen just a few
months ago he played Bishop here to g5
and this eventually led to a pretty
quick drawing game vision ins not
playing for drawl especially with the
white pieces he's looking up top for him
he sees Nakamura won a game yesterday so
he knows that he needs to go ahead and
get a win in this position he feels
pretty confident so he has been studying
this game he said and so he decided to
play rook here to d1 adding a lot more
support on this pond pushing forward to
d5 instead of just giving it up a little
easier than he did against Magnus
Carlsen giving a lot more support with
the rook here to d1
Bishop here to f5 centralizing that
Bishop palm pushing forward here to d6
again anytime you have a passed pawn you
need to push that passed pawn just
putting more and more pressure on your
opponent's always going to be a good
thing pawn here to age 62 Bishop e2 e3
just getting more material involved in
the game you always wanted to develop
your minor pieces connect your roofs on
the back row they always do better
connected controlling these long files
are always going to be good night here
to g4 Bishop here to f4 and this is also
interesting because vision on is about
to sacrifice material with the move
after the bishop takes here on Steve 3
now we see the root come down here to e4
forcing this queen to move but then
basically hanging this Bishop here on f4
but vision on said that he had prepared
for this and this is the variation that
he actually wanted to go down so he
plays queen up here to be 5 attacking
this pawn here on b7 so after that the
rook takes here on f4 we see the Queen
up here on b7 and so all of this
material we see this bishop or this
queen here on b7 getting ready to push
forward to d7 he has the light square
Bishop that he can always deploy if he
wants to add another defender on the
square here on on d7 he has his rook
here on d1 he can always double his
rooks here on the default he wants to
add more pressure to this pawn right
here so he gave up material willingly
knowing that he had prepared and he
wants to continue to push forward with
this pawn and eventually try to promote
this we now see the rook swing over here
284 trying to hold down a little bit of
support of this nights here on a 6
because you can see Lamanna running
although up and materials just kind of
playing defense all of his pieces aren't
really coordinated the rook you're on a
eights not really connected doing much
of anything the Rick hair on a4 is
really awkwardly placed just defending
this night here on a 6 and this is even
more aquata page you never want your
night here on 86 there's no place for
its really go you can't come here to be
for just because the pawns right here
his own pawns kind of blocking it but he
really doesn't have the time or the
tempo to actually move this anywhere so
that's going to be bad and I can't come
up here to see 6 that's going to be bad
just bringing it back here to be 8 seems
terrible just seems kind of a wasted
move right here so fishing on trying to
take advantage of the fact that
his pieces are a lot more coordinated
now pushes up here to d7 and from the
here on out the word move 19 levon
aronian was taking about 20 minutes and
move he was trying to find a way to hold
on to the material but he just couldn't
find the best moves he plays Bishop here
to e4 trying to force the hand of this
Queen this Queen comes back here to be
three actually a really a nice square
attacking this rook now the bishop comes
up here to see 6 attacking this pawn
here on d7 probably a bad move from from
Levon Aronian instead he probably could
have just played rook here to a5 kind of
taking the threat away from the Queen
here but after the bishop comes up here
to see 6 although it does look like it
is you know attacking this pawn here on
d7 it allows vision on to bring his rook
up here to d6 this not only threatens
both the minor pieces here on the
sixth-ranked but also allows this rook
to come over here to d1 add even more
pressure to this d file which fishing on
is just completely dominating right now
the bishop comes up here taking on d7 he
had a few other moves he I mean he could
have tried pawn here to see for if you
wanted to not a lot of great moves
though decides to play Bishop here to d7
and then rook over here to d1 this is
again just adding more and more pressure
here there's no way to really hold on to
this D file decides to go and get his
Queen out of the way so the rook up here
taking here on d7 a queen down here
levon aronian wants to get more material
off the board can allow his opponent
with all those pieces so coordinated to
control that Queen right there but after
the pawn takes the root comes down here
to the second ring with typically is
good having your rook on your opponent's
a second rank or 7th rank depending on
your color to bring now the bishop here
to see for you can start to see all hope
kind of going away from from black all
the pieces are really coordinated from
vishy and on as bishop right here nice
little outpost attacking the square here
on f7 is rook right here attacking f7
completely dominating this d file right
here so things are definitely looking
good for white black is going to have a
hard time to hold on to even a drawl for
this game we now see black bring his
rook over here to f8 just trying to
protect this material here
on f7 again that's kind of what black
has to do he has to try to just the fin
as much as possible Rick over here to d6
you know you can always play this rook
over here to g6 takes material this pawn
can't move it is being pinned down by
this Bishop right here so that's going
to be good king here to g7 trying to
stop this attack on the g6 pawn but now
the rook can just wing over here take
this material on a6 also protected by
the bishop here on c4 which is a great
piece Rick over here taking on f2 but
that's you know it's not going to do too
much all I can do really do is take this
pawn right here so Rick over here to e1
getting ready to bring this rook over
into the action in so Levon Aronian
decides to go ahead and resign in this
position he's down a material why it's
going to be able to take this material
here on a seven if he wants to he
eventually is going to have a majority
of the pawns on the queenside he's going
to be able to push forward this rook
here on fa it's never really going to be
able to move after the truck here on on
a7 just adding too much pressure on the
King side and so black decide it's just
not worth it sweeter sign so very very
well done well done by vishy anand he
took a pretty devastating drawl in Game
seven from the World Championships not
too long ago that he really really
needed to win and he approved upon it he
studied I found definitely a better move
employed it against ronnian who just had
no answer he was just fumbling and took
way too long for all his moves and just
could never find the best way to defend
even though he was up in material so
congrats division on he goes into a tie
for first place with Nakamura with for a
first place and so will have tomorrow
round 3 but hopefully you guys enjoyed
watching hopefully you learn something
and i'll see you guys the next video
thanks for watching